una margherita
questo indicare membri allora io ho già
un miracolo se entri quando faccio la
figura
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata oggi mi prenderò
un tè in compagnia di clio benvenuta la
scorsa puntata io ho dichiarato essere
stata l'ultima puntata però in realtà è
capitato questa è passata ho detto
sempre ho iniziato con un amico con
claudio e perché non finire con un'amica
prima persona della temuta tutti estera
male ci resterà mai sapete anche voi che
poi saresti adottata da sconosciuti
cosma ti voglio un bene dell'anima però
dovete sapere che chi conosce questo
canale dagli inizi saprà che il motivo
per cui è stato inizialmente lanciato a
pallettoni
che lo ricordi che tu per pietà un
pochino
e io siamo stati amici per un sacco di
tempo poi in realtà entrambi difettate
persone di successo e ci sono cancellati
il moralista amicizie dell'altro più che
altro brutto stronzo voglio dire una
cosa ha passato gli ultimi venti minuti
e farmi vedere le foto di me
tu sei denti
detto ciò sentiti possa offrire qualcosa
da bere non farmi essere un cafone rai è
qualcosa di alcolico storia va bene ma
sì che l'acqua
è quello e 34 apriamo qua chiudiamo
ragazzi in tutto questo fatemi sapere
qua sotto se notate con qualcosa di
diverso in questo set abbiamo avuto un
piccolo disagio un razzo letto no no no
agghiaccio
ah ok
partiamo con la puntata di vita buttata
[Musica]
allora clio ti spiego al volo come
funzione format ascoltiamo degli audio
di commentiamo possono essere qualsiasi
cosa intenda per scontate non abbia mai
visto niente di tuo no ma lo sto
ripetendo per chi ci sta seguendo al
momento visto che sicuramente avremo un
sacco di persone che verranno qui per
vedere te pensa veramente la cazzata
della nostra amicizia del motivo per cui
ha invitato qui perché c'era un forte
legame di 13 anni ma coperte anche
voler assolutamente è un insieme di
interessi capenti si cui cose sta
uscendo adesso l'unica balma comprate
lucrava armi comprate
visto che di lui in persona non conosce
entrambi ingiallire be nice zurigo stare
insieme che esistano insurgents e perché
avevamo fatto anche documenti questo
faccio questo non lo so parlaci
prendendo parlo uomini di low cost a una
rottura che dice del minuto e stare
insieme e lui fa tutto libero de libero
perché sanzione io sono un campione io
sto con nessuno ci sono tante persone
cose in giro che poi anche i documenti
per sposare no quello no quella grave
tipo io prima di claudio non avevo mai
conosciuto una persona che possa 20
disposta a mettersi in gioco al cento
per cento capisco bene quello che dice
perché ci sono tante persone sia uomini
che donne non vogliono legarsi perché
hanno paura di essere in gabbia quindi
per la cosa triste perché io sono stato
anche molto abituato a pensare che
l'amore fosse quello che tu avevi nei
confronti di due persone che sotto sotto
si disprezza o non ti vuole abbastanza
quando si dice la conquista in realtà la
conquista secondo me è vera fino a un
certo punto perché vi rottura di cui
nel tempo sia solo quello finisce tra un
po accentrerà un pezzo di ponte qua
dentro noi dovremo mettere i lucchetti
perché credo che la metà delle frese
predetto sono presenta il libro di
moccia
proprio quel coso un invito che la sua
filosofia quale siamo ancora se mi fa
capire ma realmente ringrazio smentirlo
che aiutano gli anziani sorridere
termini e quando metti lo stesso bene
nei suoi tre cani partono kennedy nel
terrore fotogallery finale un altro
tutto invece la informatico a dormire
argomento lettori franco lerda il tesoro
del sottile fammi vedere sai qualche
punto nero sulla schiena nei passi
speciali sono due cose
ben distinte
che tipo di rapporti hai tu con gli
animali quando ai momenti privati il
capro fatto finire io c'è un miracolo
sentry quando faccio la pipì anche
meglio poteva andare molto peggio
lamenti che questo qui di partito e che
tornava
invece preso arrivava e creavano un
minotauro seconda cosa di punti ne ha
anch'io ho trovato soddisfacente diciamo
anche se abbiamo queste passioni magari
teniamole magari per il quinto sesto
appuntamento sono l'unica che
l'impressione che l'amore sia arma
alimentato come prodotto da supermercato
che si possa cambiare sostituire e
comprarne quanti te ne pare piace perché
qualcuno che crede ancora che possano
esistere i rapporti d'amore che non sono
ormai prodotti da altre cose insomma
superficiali quando mia nonna era
giovane che tu fossi innamorata non
fosse amato dovevi stare per forza
insieme e questo già un ottimo punto al
cuore partire culturalmente è vero una
volta che vi fatto quella scelta era
quella la generazione poi di mia mamma è
stata la prima vera e propria
generazione dei corsi lo avevo 14 anni
quando mi hanno divorziato prima stato
un trauma percorso contro ma per me
penso che per me una liberazione
liberazione totale io voglio fare un
altarino le stanze non è sbagliato
parlare amore secondo me quello che è
diventato molto più intercambiabile usa
e getta sono le persone se ci pensi le
nostre nonne che opzioni che possibilità
però di conoscere gente poi è arrivato
internet quello che ad oggi è il vero
problema è che noi ci sentiamo di avere
il mondo da poter selezionare un tempo
tra accontentare anche di più avevi meno
termini di paragone se il tuo
supermercato avesse solo un cereale ti
prenderesti quello sentiva di giocare a
un giochetto che preparano per te
partiamo col segmento
[Musica]
però scartato non mi piacciono
con un vestitino e cole al quale stan
smith giornali oa 10 super cos'è che hai
un brand fortissimo lo sappiamo tutti
quanti comprate per cui ho detto ma
perché non chiedere all'inter atrice
ormai del trucco a collega insegnato al
mondo a truccarsi che quindi sicuramente
brava con i pennelli con le palette e
tutto quanto di tornare proprio alle
basi e disegnare è che tu sai che io non
so disegnare sia proprio la mente allora
la persona che sta dietro deve disegnare
sulla schiena e la persona avanti dovrà
intuire a seconda di quello che sente
sulla schiena il disegno che sta facendo
e riprodurlo non aspetta
però quanto ci metterà molto bello
tornare un altro nonno sotto è un grande
quesito che si pongono un sacco di
persone che interagiscono con me vado
[Musica]
oltretutto state prendendo le uniche
cose che so disegnare e non scherzo so
già che cos'è che avrai sicuramente
quando ok per disegnare gli dice mamma
mi dai qualcosa in ditemi se questa cosa
oltre a jackie del cos'è
[Musica]
che cosa che chiede grace di farle la
monnalisa
iniziato la mia giacca rosa o da opposto
di me non puoi andare questo pennarello
anzi sì col cavolo
inquadrato
nel quadrato rettangolo in grande guarda
che cosa hai fatto tu che ti definisci
mia lingua che ti faccio la firma se mi
esce adesso clistere mascara io giuro
che la fiom paletto make up
io questo mi rifiuto pinguino che
abbraccia un cuore ma
questa mela al collo appena finito
guarda
disegnando da quel cerchio
ma col cerchio
gatti
hai le fa solo
non sta nemmeno seguendo le medicazioni
no è babbo natale è arrivato di tipo
così e lo kitty
tu hai fatto sto sgorbio per andare a
dominare cosa era una cosa positiva come
detto tu e che per truccarsi non serve
saper disegnare
è la clessidra
fammi finire spoiler non è un aggressiva
senti qua
[Musica]
quant ed inizia così titolarissimo è ma
come meno
consueti mediante più o meno
proprio
vicino era vicina e secondo me non si
capisce cosa disegnato il giocatore è
una conchiglia anche questo tela buona
perché i rialzi stata brava 6 st grava è
buy torniamo alla realtà difficile
comunque rata delle farfalle e fa parte
che sa fare abbastanza bene perché può
donare prima cosa ha imparato a fare
scuola di jose bellissima farfalla così
in giro dire ma da quando gli stronzi al
mi è stata polare
[Musica]
nome tir in luce professor mark ii sta
faccio un venduto o nonché uscire di
testate a rischio a raggiungerlo varie
linee o ancora di tutti questi sono
sintomi non trovo si è presentata per la
fa quando il 3 della rabbia della
reggina non se la merita questo betis
siviglia
no ci sono timori di lavaggio si farà
sentire gli ho pregato per tutto il
sento deprivata
iscritto uno brutto quando di farlo
liberamente nessuna certezza chi siete
non si chiedeva quando che c'era scritto
utilizzano ambiente scusa scusa
il kit figlia mia a parte il fatto che
c'è una somma voglia oggi secondo ci
sono sul mercato delle cose che in tutti
i tipi
purtroppo anche a volte da una regola
quando un capo ti fa uscire di testa non
farlo entrare nessuna parte ok questo
indicare i membri è la maschera un po
con questa voglia però su qualcos'altro
anche sotto probabilmente avrebbe
cercato anche altrove perché noi ci
dobbiamo chiudere la gente e la cosa
sbagliata che tu pensi di punirlo quando
noi non interessiamo una persona non c'è
niente che non amo fare per farla stare
male quanto stiamo male noi a meno che
non se ne pazzi e non so come dire che
buca del motorino cioè cosa che vi
sconsigliamo
60 la possibilità che stiano male per
qualcun altro per non pesare mia mente
si
aggiungeva per alcun altra cosa ok che a
volte noi vediamo una cattiveria è
semplicemnte un ragazzo non è
interessato cioè non è che può essere
una merda
che dobbiamo fare è la cosa è molto
semplice se cerchi diciamo morto se
cerchi il cactus cercano altrove il
mondo è pieno di piante grasse ma
ricordo che oltretutto perché sociale
spine se c'è chi cactus arrivano anche
sempre spine insieme al cactus
bravissimo come sono cactus o poi
mi fai venire voglia di ascoltare ultime
stagioni vederti mai più per almeno
facciamo grace quando prende la patente
ha 53 anni
cinquanta spoiler fra 80 anni il sistema
sono morti non ci vedo da tre anni ma
può venire qui a rompere con il tempo
che passa
la morte imminente continua giornale
quel ragazzo 18 anni colti figlie cioè
nel senso cioè noi siamo i primi 26
guardi ti stai conosciuti il rapporto ne
parlo con te
perché
adesso siamo carne per farci è
chiarissimo ma che cosa hanno
oscar nini qui no perché la cosca
guglielmo già ospite niente praticamente
nove anni fa stanno facendo le
università a los angeles
io le mie amiche decidiamo di andare
alla svegliaste stream per niente una
serata siamo in una discoteca incontro
questo ragazzo australiano molto fico
molto simpatico balliamo la serata dopo
pure ci rivediamo e succede così che
succede niente poi l'editor nella strada
io ritorno a los angeles
nove anni dopo siamo insieme da anni e
ci stavo per sposare quindi l'aneddoto è
che quello che succede a las vegas non
rimane mai a las vegas ha però
chiudiamo perché questo era l'ultimo
audio con
come stavo qui a deprimerci di una
chitarra dire ma ti rendi conto se
rivangando anche il nostro passato e
così e poi chiudiamo alcun una roba
bellissima perché noi possiamo cercare
di prevedere quello che ci capiterà ma
la vita non la puoi prevedere nel male
ma anche nel bene vero bella bella
storia ed è per questo che io che ti
ringrazio sia perché ci conosciamo 13
anni sia perché ci vogliamo molto bene e
sia perché siamo la prova per cui
secondo me quando sei amico di qualcuno
e questa persona dei successi e come se
fossero anche tuoi quindi l'amicizia di
bagnoli e amicizia che mi ha detto di
avere più successo ti lascio il libano
ovviamente grazie di cuore per essere
passata
74 anni la e grazie a voi ragazzi a cima
note i messaggi che alza poi per tutto
quello che avete fatto per questa
stagione vita buttata noi adesso ci
prendiamo una pausa questo cosa vuol
dire che da giovedì inizieremo con un
nuovo format riprenderemo con la seconda
stagione
dopo l'estate quindi godetevi restante
potete di nuovo format io mando bacio
ciao
comprate